well it's pride once again and i think i  want to kick off this pride similar to  how i did last time let's start with the  basics defining  the letters  lgbtqia  plus  that's the term that i use it's the one  you'll see most frequently these days  from people trying to be as inclusive as  possible what do they mean l lesbian be  bisexual g  gay t transgender q queer or questioning  queer in general is a bit of a blanket  term i intersex a asexual not  ally asexual and then the plus is for  any other queer identity not covered by  the other specific letters  so  those are the people for whom we are  celebrating pride sometimes you'll see  longer ones with more letters some  people will use a shorter one some  people put the plus after the t  but these are all the people who are  included  happy pride